on we lost we have had him as a guest
his mother Paul Shore Pauly Shore
Pauly Shores mother passed away last
week Mitzi shore oh no it was Wednesday
right the Wednesday she passed away but
she's been sick for a very long time
Mitzi I mean essentially they discovered
me which doesn't really mean much to I
guess you guys but it means how you got
your start in fact I don't think there's
one person you've talked about more on
this podcast than Mitzi shore
you've credited her you've credited your
entire career to her each and every time
well because you know you look at the
Comedy Store comics of today they most
of them were not passed by her because
she got sick a long time ago so she
stopped coming around so then you know
people that get passed as a regular at
The Comedy Store was done by whoever the
talent coordinator was Tommy or right
now Adam Egan Paulie and those guys have
a lot of say but me Sebastian Maniscalco
there's a couple of us that are still
Mitzi passes I think I saw is it Nick
you suppose Nick Youssef was the very
last we could have been the last one
yeah he was the last one that she passed
and she passed him which means she was
going senile at that point yes shout out
to Nick but I'm sorry but she was going
to sing a hell if she passed you okay
but Mitzi I'll just have that what if I
talked about how I met her tell us again
yeah all right so I was working at the
Comedy Store in La Jolla
and I was a doorman and I borrowed back
and whatnot and one night at open mic I
ran into Paul II I was a kid I was 23
and Paulie goes did there's something
about your bra something weird about you
did I go thank you and he goes did I'm
gonna have you open for me one day
soon like maybe nine months later
because deed you're gonna do Vegas with
me brah
so then you know I was working there as
a doorman but he flew me to Vegas and
this is when he was um he was doing like
5,000 seats at the top of the rib
riviera there's a gigantic like showroom
up there
and he had me do five minutes that's all
I could do you know five minutes do you
remember that set no I don't
I remember being petrified absolutely
petrified and there was another guy
named wild Willy Parsons is old like
trucker guide that was featuring big guy
and Paulie goes deed my mom's here brah
right yeah and I saw her before the show
but I was just like there's no way did
you know the importance of her at that
time Laurie oh yeah yeah oh yeah I mean
we yeah we knew that she was the owner I
mean we knew the history of her but also
at the time it's like you know you just
think there's no way she's gonna like me
or whatever and I went up I don't know
if I did good or not but I got offstage
and she just walks right up to me and
she just goes hi I'm Mitzi and I go she
goes you're a regular at all my clubs
congratulation ho you didn't even have
to showcase no I just five minutes in
from her and she made me a regular you
must have done well then it's not that
if I look back
it's imagine what I you know the slub
King everyone knows a slep King
everyone knows no salt or papaya
everything everyone knows the science of
life and the things that and alert and
the things that we you know talk about
here you know the the dream weaving the
connections the spiritual laws between
our souls up or lower case you know
energy dementia marvelous reactions
within each other despite interactions
without yourself
[Laughter]
so and these are things that I believe
these are things that I I'm gonna put
down in a book one day
but multitasking within each cell
creates an upper hemisphere of life
components that we in itself cannot
understand and yet they exist you never
thought about it that way no but I'm
telling you that that's the fact and
that's of great it's it to be written
stone it's written in stone but the
thing is is that so you have to imagine
this kind of mesmerizing entity this
lepke's Lepke yeah as a kid younger
person and she witnessed it you know she
touched it she she you know absorbed it
and what people they meet this love King
yeah you get absorbed my fluids first
okay I exude this like who's not who's
is this like I have if you don't if you
if you put like what so those the aura
how you can see someone's aura or heat
or heat anyway if you if you're a
predator predator like the predator a
guy right
like the hint for Red's the infrared
stuff yeah my infrared heat from my body
it's tripled the amount of a normal
human beings know that that's red it's
pure red right and it's hate it's all of
its a hate and anger and rage but and
what happens is that people when they
get too close to the slump King they
absorb some of my heat which Denton's
turns to liquid which then gets absorbed
into their skin and then they become
infected in a good way
bad and good some people have died I'll
be able to but like Mitzi's witness dead
you know and even the five minutes and
so you know she made me a regular and um
and then over the years she used to come
down to La Jolla in her limo she this
brown limo and my old friend Freddy Soto
used to be his limo driver and we would
go to the steakhouse called bullies
and we would eat and she would say wise
knowledge like um in as a sin to support
mediocrity you know what makes a star
half the people have to love you but
other other half the people have to hate
you at the same time like the different
things that I still believe today and um
yeah she passed away Wednesday and I
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] didn't go to the
service because I had to go to Denver
[Music]